hey everybody my name is chef Marcus
Sampson and today we're actually cooking
one of my favorite chicken it's a fried
chicken then we're gonna toss in a
chocolate sauce yes you heard it right
chocolate sauce what am I thinking is
our chicken shake it is delicious I put
it on everything so this thing should
really come from a love for fried
chicken you might have heard of it we
have a place called Red Rooster with the
bird is came now just give it a good old
shake sometimes I call it chicken snow
and you get it this is absolutely
delicious so I got water I'm gonna bring
this to you're born with salt and then
when it's cooled down we're gonna pour
it on top of the chicken I love to brine
my chicken if you want to really do some
bird there's a couple of steps you want
to do bone-in dark meat and brine the
bird put a lid on let's sit minimum two
hours or overnight so the marinade I
love this marinade so I did this from my
buddy James who actually did this sauce
on a beef brisket it was so good and
James
he just loves Mexican food and I love
Mexican food so we took the chocolate
sauce up in love with Fried Chicken
marry the two together toss toss there
it is
key step the chocolate sauce and this
chocolate sauce is so rich and delicious
and you're gonna see why it's all about
the spices and flavor that we're going
to add on to this dish food for me it's
all about flavor but making great
flavors takes time got a little bit heat
here I'm gonna add in the chillies and
adding as much sure like it's a rich
sauce right so it's beer
chocolate spices all simmer together
we're gonna let this simmer and then
it's gonna add in chocolate and butter
this sauce is good for any time you want
to grill or you want to fry something
and we brush the sauce on top it will be
delicious so I'm gonna dredge it the
same lean on the cornstarch all there
for flour they're all there to make it
crunchy we're just gonna whisk that I
love decent oil I'm just flinging the
garlic when I heat up the oil to put in
big gulp close in and then I'm taking
them out just for labor right and it's
12 minutes then let it rest the rest
important key so it stays nice and juicy
we got a beautiful chocolate sauce in
there right look at that nice this is so
delicious now we're just gonna have a
little bit of heat and then finish to
brighten up with a little bit of fresh
herb
I love eating this dish with my friends
fry it because there's a dish way talk
about finger smacking finger licking
good good it's rich and delicious and
it's also something to do the spring and
summer eyes you wait for those picnics
you wait for those barbecues everyone in
your family is gonna love this meal I'm
guarantee you all right guys come in and
eat we're ready we excited come on bird
for you ladies first and you want that
crunch you want this like mmm get that
chocolate lipstick
good right
you